welcome to this video this is coverage
of the second gushy morph memorial plate
currently in chunkier azerbaijan yes i'm
doing a tournament coverage again
covering this tournament that started
just today the first round it's a
10-player round robin and features some
of the best players we have your
champion magnus carlsen we have caruana
mamedyarov vishy anand so Wesley so yeah
going to mention them all in the video
so I'm not doing like big playa
biographies now and yeah I'm going to
cover the whole tournament round by
round um what I'm doing a little bit
differently to two other tournament
coverages is going to cover all the
games but I won't be as detailed as I've
been in the past I don't want to create
90-minute videos for each round I want
to show some some key points so
interesting points and yeah provide you
with an overview what happened in the
round but it won't be like to our
experience with every move detected so
let's get going I'm focusing on some
games a little bit more some games a
little bit less starting with the first
game yet Mammadov with wide against for
Sheila graph you very likely will know
the French player with the black pieces
but Ralph mummy Dolph is not as well
known as a number three player of
Azerbaijan on mama dr office the number
one number one guy and the second one
would be a job off but he couldn't make
it for this tournament so they invited
the number three of their azerbaijani
rating list yeah mammadov is an
aggressive attacking player but here
against mvl see 5d6 he goes for the
check on beehive yeah this this line is
getting more and more popular
very much due to the efforts of carlson
it leads to very often share this kind
of position where r to those pretty
normal looking moves we get this maroc
see blind structure with pawns on c4 and
d4 against this typical Sicilian dragon
build up here we get this which provides
a wide with some space advantage and are
those booths are all looking very very
normal ya b3 yeah we have this is the
typical maroc see bind focusing to
control with d5 and putting a not this
one I wanted to actually undelete yeah I
wanted to point out this is 25 square
it's nicely controlled and why does some
in general maintaining yeah a very nice
grip on the position so mamedov choice
is meant to be very safe and this is
what is basically the theme of this game
he plays it safe and rook see 197 rook
t1 all very normal natural moves and the
blacks problem is that he has less space
and what you normally want to do when
you have less space is to trade pieces
however training pieces will lead to
simplifications and we see what happens
black is and trading some stuff here and
now goes for b5 that's an active move
taking this bind and white cannot easily
grab stuff here let's say if he tries to
take on b5 there's a to pawn that will
fall as a compensation for b5 yeah so
black is first trading some pieces too
yeah give give him a little bit more
maneuvering space with this creme that
he wasn't in always be five his counter
attacking white structure yeah and well
mama mama dog just centralized with 95
and we got them strains in him and
Knight b6 with a further trade note that
black was not able to just put something
on the sea far because of this needle
tactic that wins who will rook but
Knight b6 is fine black is trading the
strong d5 night and after Quincy 795
shaklee even had Queens off yet if you
look at this end game it's a rook
endgame equal parts white has two
against one this looks like a slight
symbolic advantage like you might get a
pastor a passed pawn there but like it's
very quick in getting his King into the
game and after a couple of more moves
they continued a little bit and let's
see i'm not sure about the draw rules of
this journal but after 40 moves they
about 40 moves here here they called it
a day it is simply a total draw the a
porn is constantly attacked by blacks
rook and why it is never able to push it
forward black however doesn't have
anything active himself if he at one
moment tries to do something um on them
let's say on attacking the the sorry not
this one taking the King side then the a
pawn runs chatham you see that it is
unstoppable yeah if black is checking
there's rook be one and you won't be
able to stop the airport from promoting
so we have a repetition there that is
completely forced why discontinuously
attacking the rook and black cannot
deviate yeah a very safe draw for
mammadov he's certainly okay with
starting with this half point he's
totally new to those super top level
events I think he never played a
tournament that strong so you want to
get your yeah get your name on the
scoreboard the draw is certainly fine
for him okay let's look at the next game
and this is Mammadyarov the other by
Johnny number one against fabiano
caruana currently think world number two
kind of jacket was up and down there in
the life
let's see what we get we have a
Greenfeld yeah very popular opening
nowadays and Mammadyarov goes for a
Bishop f4 set up that was I was kind of
intrigued to see that because I was
studying this line a little bit myself
recently and corona came up with c5
that's very normal move against general
in the gruene felt your fee on Chet oh
you put d5 and see if I've out but here
this move has a actually quite dodgy
reputation it's quite interesting that
he was playing it the reason why it has
a dodgy reputation lies in the line d
take c5 queen 85 which is kind of the
normal move that's always played and now
cd5 9525 gypsy three Bishop d2 yeah and
here it is um yeah here Bishop b6 as
them the old main line which doesn't
seem to work and Bishop t2 Queen d2 chat
commun c5 rook c1 is also very awkward
so this is the reason why this line has
a dodgy reputation but after d take c5
yeah mamedyarov actually took a while
there it was probably surprised that
this was coming from corona then Kara
wanna played 94 and if you look at the
clock times this is really amazing after
six moves Quran had spent 30 minutes
mama dro of eight minutes around nine
minutes but karana 30 minutes half an
hour office two hours and well the way
it should be i'll move six so if he was
prepare or had prepared that why was he
taking 30 minutes for it 94 actually
here is a total novelty that has never
been played and on the only six and a
complete mainstream opening this is kind
of a yeah for some for opening buffs
this is kind of sensational then there's
something like that coming and the
craziest thing is Kara has spent 30
minutes on it this is probably even more
irritating for my manyara firm
compared to if Khurana would have just
played it instantly then it okay it's
some kind of preparation yet and you
have to deal with it but what what
exactly is the guy telling you with okay
I just sense birdies I just spent 30
minutes on that did you just invent it
over the board kind of kind of hard to
believe okay it's very interesting first
of all you ask yourself what is
happening in this position yeah white
has many options actually he decided to
take on e4 Whitehead other moves 95 for
example that looks very nice yeah
getting this the threat in but after
night a 6 it turns out that black is
quite okay he will get the c5 pawn back
and he has of course those Queen a5
check IDs all of the time the
combination of those two ideas will give
get legged will regain one pawn and very
often you can base your play around this
super strong Bishop there um one line
that is interesting is for example this
one let's say 92 black captures their on
c5 and now interesting idea for why it
is to play before it looks funky but
interesting yeah Bishop takes on a 1 is
1 1 point now if that happens Queen a1
we are dealing with this threat and the
night is hanging so black cannot take he
has to retreat Bishop g3 and now black
may take the exchange it's a very very
interesting position now I think white
has excellent compensation for the
exchange it's got a pawn a great night
on d5 yeah very interesting so white had
tons of interesting possibilities even
besides 95 there also will see txt 5
this kind of thing is also possible
takes takes if Black gets the pawn
bishop d2 and again we would sacrifice
the exchange but we have an excellent
compensation here with those two
advanced porn cm yeah and castles would
yeah probably it's difficult to keep the
exchanges what I'm trying to say move
like bishop age 6 is attacking the rook
and threatening mate yeah black might
play Queen
five it's complicated so mamedyarov
actually was faced with this novelty and
he had really ton of possibilities I'm
just scratching on the surface here so
here ultimately took them which is quite
logical because your spoiler castling
rights yeah it is quite interesting to
do a comparison here if black instead of
c-5 would have played castles which is
the main move after III see 5d takes d5
there is also 94 this is a well-known
line and the big difference is that now
in the actual game black hasn't canceled
so Knight takes e4 is completely wrong
in this position as black will just
regained this pawn and he doesn't have
to worry about castling rights in the
game and all of a sudden like lost his
right to castle and white is actually
ready for long castling with check yeah
so after that that we came to this
position where Mammadyarov took on b8
yeah he also could have played the night
but one problem might be that if you
think about this f5 and e5 coming then
this Bishop is actually not very well
placed a very interesting opening idea
where Korra wanna I mean I cannot really
say that this is kind of revolutionizing
this line it's very early for that but I
found it pretty interesting that he came
up with such an early idea yeah in the
game we got a position where black is a
pawn down but he has two bishops and he
has ideas to get the sea porn back white
quite quickly and this is actually what
happened black what's getting this horn
back at some point but wide as a
compensation let's say Oh in the
meantime got some again some time on the
queenside he had some play there with
rookie invading on the 7th rank and well
I think that it was a very it looks like
a very young yeah sensible sound game
why it had some pressure here on the
queenside but it doesn't didn't look
yeah very very threatening for black
however we came to one interesting
moment and this is coming here on booth
where is it i think it's move 30 let's
just go ahead a little bit here in this
particular moment after b5 the bishop
here has attacked on c6 and karen i
could have put it on f3 jaan e 4 but he
decided to totally change the position
he just sacrificed his bishop
interesting decision now he just
liquidated those two pawns and accepted
a transformation to an end game we can
see now that here chad is very much
forced that we got to this position
where at the end he's got we can put
this on the board he got three pawns
against two he's a bishop down but he
will get a position where white is
either he has either has to give up all
in sports or will be settled with the h
porn and the h pawn is the wrong porn
it's a dark squared yeah this is a dark
square the h eight squared you have a
light squared Bishop which means that if
we trade rooks in this and it sir just
go on a little bit here we had this
straight if we now would have rooks
traded the pure endgame Bishop and pawn
against the pure king is a draw this
funny draw where you get the wrong
colored bishop as it is called and this
is of course increasing the draw
probability yeah enormously black will
draw here with the rook trade and He
will draw with simply trading off all
pawns because rook and Bishop against
rook is a draw it's still has to be
played but it is a draw and in the game
we alternate liao track check while we
got go to this end game check yeah the e
porn is the source for counter play and
ultimately there was nothing better form
wyd to get to this and this is as
mentioned to draw they played it out for
a couple of moves but Kara wanna never
got into any trouble I don't know how
long they inflated actually to move 90
so they didn't they didn't go the the
whole way here almost 33 moves ya on
that level they simply hold the draw and
it was increment with increment time
after 60 moves there they get an
increment of 30 seconds so there wasn't
a danger of anyone losing on time yeah
this game was interesting due to the
opening novelty mostly this early
opening novelty is kind of kind of
interviewing that you have novelty on
move 6 I don't know if this stands or
not kind of interesting is also karana
spent 30 minutes there it's quite um
quite surprising okay so next game let's
go to kramnik with white against Micky
Adams we have neither 305 and after g3
cromley gets kind of yeah insisting on
that nowadays he plays this set up quite
often Adams is opting for a very
classical approach he just treats it
like a Queens gambit declined let's say
and puts in those moves d5 e6b should be
79 f6 preparing to castle he's not
opting for something where the bishop is
outside of the pawn chain which is also
quite often played here you get a king's
in unitech red tea or the Catalan and
it's the Catalan in this case chrome
Dickens of course a well-known
specialist in this opening yeah here
Adams goes for details see form the
absolute main line of this where wide
now has a big choice he can play Quincy
to a 6 a-4 he can take on c4 or he can
deviate right on move seven Quincy to us
by far the main line okay software is
lagging a bit um it Queen c2 is by far
the main line as I just put on the board
but there's also the move 95
a 95 was played by Kramnik 95 is an
interesting alternative for people who
prepare who prepare know who prefer a
very straightforward concrete approach
to to the game because it basically
forces black to do something that is
some leading to very very concrete play
um the thing is what takes on c4 with
the night if black is just doing
something very yeah let's say
non-committal if pic is doing something
like that let's say we will take and we
will enjoy this great Bishop all the
time Black is simply under pressure in
this position he has huge problems to
develop the bishop so black is here in
this position he's um yeah on in high in
a higher sense almost forced to play the
move knight c6 which looks kind of who
we had at first but it is definitely the
the main move and the most popular one
black is sacrificing upon their white
can take the nineteen to waste bishop c6
or 96 Bishop c6 was played by chrome
neck after takes Knight takes we fork
those two and weenie eight teams takes
and this is some in the position that is
a key for the whole variation here white
is after night 83 Queen a4s the
alternative trying to get the pawn back
and just have one extra porn yeah that
would be very nice but black has a
bishop on c8 later coming maybe here and
why doesn't have a fee and Chatwood
bishop anymore so it's a situation where
then very the next couple of moves are
very very important to see if black is
getting compensation for the potentially
lost porn you played c5 forever and
counter-attack the d4 pawn rook the
eighth is an additional idea now to put
some pressure here against the Queen
only one DC 5 CLE takes Bishop e3 with
the tempo yeah this is a known position
and here the most
before and queen age five both have been
played before by absolute top top level
players and especially important is the
move Queen h5 because this was played in
a game kramnik aren't so this was no
surprise for Adams let's say if it was a
surprise he had didn't prepare properly
and he definitely had this on the board
i'm pretty pretty sure he went with
Queen to c6 also relatively quickly
played and Luke see one was crumb next
move Bishop d7 f3 yeah should avoid mate
Bishop a 6 yeah and now we see okay well
what is this is this something for white
hmm if white wants to have something
here he has to play exactly as chromic
did he took this pawn on c4 relying on
Bishop c4 Queen D for getting the pawn
back that looks really nice why does
getting this this Bishop back and at
first you think white might keep an
extra pawn but black after rook c8 b3
Queen a6 will actually gained upon you
will get the a to pawn and now Kramnik
play King f2 covering the party too very
interesting after this opening sequence
which in some likelihood the players
have have seen have seen before we get a
position where white is a little bit
better yeah and this is due to the fact
that White's bishop is a little bit
better than blacks night at the moment
the night here on f6 it's looking at
squares that are controlled it cannot go
anywhere and the white Bishop is looking
at this pawn and might support the white
pawn with advancing further also black
screen is a little bit of sight the
whole situation is a little bit more
comfortable for white and have to be
completely honest there I'm not totally
sure at which point in the upcoming
moves Adams is slipping
because spoiling spoiling white got
somewhere but I'm not really sure where
blacks mistake was um I looked a bit but
i'm not completely completely sold on a
particular spot where i think okay there
this is one this is a mistake it's also
noting where you can just switch on the
computer and it tells you why that was
bad it's really not the case he's kind
of slipping slowly into problems we will
see that if I if that looks like a good
move yeah with this idea oops sorry yeah
all of the sudden widest in trouble but
the Queen doesn't have to take when to
d6 yeah and you see that Bishop f6 is a
is a tricky move yeah Bishop f6 will be
destroy black spawn structure and you
cannot move the night away here black
had an interesting opportunity in going
'uh form not a very obvious move but an
interesting one after Bishop f6 black
takes and get some counter player on the
on the e to pawn your queen takes it to
a threat and if white takes the king
also will be quite insecure let's say G
takes and well this position is not
clear to me maybe this is better than
the game it's an interesting way to at
least getting rid of night against
bishop but I'm not sure how bad this is
actually what what what Adams played yet
still looks very logical he gained some
tempe on white screen and okay a little
trick there with the back rank black
cannot take the Queen check because I
made this this check made them yeah but
rupee eight why is why exactly it's
black worse maybe because of Bishop f6
which is hard to prevent I can tell you
one thing that around here it is
definitely difficult to play this
position blacks king is worse and white
see porn is more dangerous than blacks a
pawn due to the support of the rooks so
white is combining now the 7th ranked
play with the sea pawn I mean maybe
there is some kind of defense for
like but it's very very awkward to play
note that they have here I mean Adams on
nine minutes crumbling on ten they play
without an increment in the first 60
moves so this is pure pure time trouble
let's say at 12 moves nine minutes it's
not like super hectic but don't think
Adams is getting 30 seconds per move he
just has to play this with exactly the
nine minutes there may be here queen bee
to was a better defense that's possible
trying to try to play it like that and
have their pawn as an option I mean
white can always kind of check like a
discussion yeah trying to operate with
threats like this and trying for this
but black has counter play with the a
porn maybe that was a better option he
went for up to eight and now after Luke
87 it looks very tricky the a poor now
is under serious pressure and white is
simply threatening to get to take it
after some preparation rooks III Queen
III yeah those kind of moves they might
just pick up the pawn and Queen B to
rugby one yeah white is better
coordinated he has chances to get both
rooks on the seventh yeah this is a
tactical sequence now but something that
definitely leads to a good wide position
Kramnik now simply um yeah Eustace
transformation to his advantage after
this Luke c2 he has a rook endgame if we
do account one extra pawn and his behind
his passer so white is much much better
here and probably close to a win after
this yeah it's difficult for black now
to avoid the rook trade if you I mean
you can but why does invading here and
he has this very well supported porn
yeah Adams played the rook trade and
after that it's definitely over after d4
if black is pushing you have d5 and
those two would do a home run
again after the capture King you to hear
Adams resigned white is just picking up
this pawn and we win the end game we can
look a bit how this would unfold if here
yeah here black will have to move the
king or the rook at some point he is
running out of moves and then he can
play this but after age for you now have
to do something and whatever you do with
the white king will invade or the root
will have to yeah allow the white pawn
to be pushed something like that is a
very simple win black is running out of
moves yeah like this this and white is
picking up everything as you cannot move
the rook or the or the or the king so
very very easy win yeah probably if we
go back there somewhere around here
Adams players to be improved the move
Queen B 2 is probably probably the way
to go which still is difficult to play
but seems like a better defense and what
you did this transformation into the
double rook endgame look Jim yeah very
very problematic for black so um yeah
Kramnik got a little bit of something
out of the opening had some pressure and
with that i'm taking down adams couldn't
couldn't hold the position um next game
is wesley so with white against arnesh
geary let's see how this one unfolded we
have one c4 yeah westleigh so is also
very versatile player and his openings
he plays all of the moves c4 not so much
but it is some very often used against
players wear the white player has the
suspicion that there is screwing fault
coming up and c4 is avoiding the gruene
felt very reliably as yeah let's say 9f
693 you want to go for d5 what is ready
to go E 4 and now it's going to be a
king's indian very likely or black has
to commit to d5 very very early in a
situation where white is not yet
plate oops not yet played d4 so that's
also not greenford after Jesus rillette
same so it's an interesting weapon for
them for the white player if you don't
mind to play the pure English to avoid
the green fault yeah what did gear we do
we play g6 that's an interesting move
that nowadays is played quite often by
greenford players the idea is that after
deform you get your opening after Knight
f3 you can play Knight f6 and maybe
later go for d5 wait until the force
plate or the third option white can go
efore and now it's a tricky business how
do you avoid getting into a king's
indian yeah let's say if you go Bishop
g7 why it goes d 46 and you are in a
modern defense or in a king's indian
after let's say 93 9 f 6 yeah they have
a different idea they go each fire which
looks weird a little bit weird let's
move on but it is quite quite pointed
for example if white now goes Knight f3
Bishop g7 deform trying to play in the
center lake has a very interesting setup
in this attacking the pawn & castling
this looks a lot like a king's indian
but one key difference is that black has
not played the move d6 so after this
sequence he actually can play c6 and
possibly d5 in one go which leads to a
really nice position for black very
interesting way to play this is set up
so what should why do you if 93 isn't
any good they play deform trying to
strike in the center if black now takes
Queen takes this situation is a bit
awkward yeah the rook is hanging and you
have to do some move that you don't want
to play let's say Bishop here and i have
to go Bishop e7 as this is losing the
house so black cannot take on the form
he plays Knight f6 yeah I'm just
explaining all those things to to show
why this is this wiki sequence is played
yeah there are there are reasons
and then we get a very weird position
now Knight f6 is attacking the pawn the
normal move now most come with an idea
three it looks kind of kin of logically
and we increase the pressure and after
takes white goes e5 interesting but
Wesley so is pain differently plays an
old move d take c5 this is really almost
a forgotten line hasn't been played for
quite a while after 94 he went Bishop d3
I mean actually don't understand why it
is not played because it looks fairly
not to call you take that and now you're
trying to play against this exposed
piece only for ya Gary here check when
for this check he took a long while
indicating that he wasn't totally
familiar with with this with this line
or maybe couldn't remember what what he
had prepared at some point but yeah the
real surprise of the the point of whites
move on and now or what setup came now
as Wesley so played King f1 note that 30
minutes spent yeah he was thinking here
so he did not like this wasn't prepared
yeah opening bombshell or everything
yeah he just i mean he may be thought
about it over the board or if he had
prepared it at some point he had to
recall some some key variations yeah
what's the point of this move king of
one the idea is that if you would have
interposed with let's say 92 it's not a
bad move at all but if you do that which
has been played before black is not
under that much pressure compared to
what we see in the game for example
after g5 takes here 92 bishop t2 Queen
d6 we get some trades in and in fact
after a three this has been played in in
games and one game is here Korchnoi with
white against the team on in the 1970s
after this black had no big problems
equalizing note that here
had his two pieces that were in play if
we go back here there was two pieces he
managed to trade them both in the
process he lost some charm and he traded
off those pieces that moved a couple of
times but at least he got them traded
after King f1 Black has a very peculiar
situation those two pieces are kind of
yeah they're they're on their own they
are not communicating very well and they
are both unprotected and it actually is
it's pretty awkward now to play for
black what what is it that you want to
do with the night give this position to
a computer it will suggest a very
surprising solution the computer move
now is d5 now it looks it looks kind of
weird this move because you think ok if
you take what is exactly is the point
after 96 a3 isn't this bishop hmm in
trouble and like this and then maybe I
check there yeah Queenie 5 hmm Jeff that
all looks very very strange what is the
idea the computer actually wants to play
the stunning move f5 and gives black
full compensation for a pawn after
taking on c7 and Queen c7 I mean I'm
actually not planning to analyze this if
this is for compensation the only thing
that I can tell you is that black
definitely has some compensation but no
human players ever going to come up with
that it looks completely wacky Dee 586
f5 I mean I really don't see any human
playing like that the computer also
suggests just retreating to have six and
says that this is compensation for black
what ya mean one thing is that white is
not very well coordinated here with his
King so I understand that this is kind
of interesting but still I don't really
think any human player would come up
with such a pawn sacrifice what Geary
did was very naturally played 95 note
he took a lots of time for it I took was
20 minutes but I think actually after 95
I'm not sure if he will be able to
equalize him we will see that he's in
some trouble Knight f3 and black when 96
that was the idea regrouping the e4
night to the SE v6 squared but one very
important thing to notice black started
the game with g6 and now it is Bishop on
before so it's not fitting well very
those fitting nothing together very well
yeah you have your dark squares here
kind of unprotected and this will be
used by wide we would see Bishop back
Knight c3 g6 yeah at some point you have
to move the c8 bishop and here wyd went
before you have a look at this position
why it is better developed yeah um
actually quite ammonia sleep laced the
King on f1 looks a little bit out of
place but if you think about it in a
different way blackheads played g6 with
this bishop kind of off-site this
actually invites some kind of attack on
the king so h4 h5 is a very natural way
for white to to continue to play and
then King f1 and rook on h1 makes
perfect sense so it really this really
looks like very very promising position
for wide in my book the computer is not
really that optimistic it just gives
wider very slight edge but I think for
from the human perspective white looks
excellent here and um we see after
Bishop f8 I know it looks kind of weird
to move it again but you want it to put
it on the long diagonal Queenie to
Bishop g7 yeah now we're sleep late
Bishop g5 again a strong move yeah with
tempo on the Queen and black now went
here it's difficult to suggest something
else if you go query seven let's say
rook do you one is hitting very very
awkward with the rook lining up there if
black takes the night white is just
taking the Queen and well wear
the Queen supposed to go if you go to c6
checkmate that's early dinner right so
you cannot save the queen even very
tricky business so black had to go
Bishop f6 true and now the trade and
Queen d2 yeah what is better developed
he has more space and he has some
attacking chances on the dark squares
not very nice disposition black went
with castles rookie one that looks
normal getting the rook into the game
Queen dat yeah it looks weird to put the
Queen back but I think gear we figured
that 94 or 95 was in the mix anyway and
so is some retreating the Queen before
the tech happens and hear what black is
doing is actually quite useful you text
this Bishop them so that white is not
able to quick win age six track due to
the hanging piece yeah white felt
inclined to play rook t1 yeah first
rookie one then rugby one but you really
want to have this possibility and black
has to be on the lookout for that he
went a five trying to create some kind
of counter play but why it wasn't really
worried so much age for that's very
logical takes takes 97 and now the move
h5 is sitting yeah a very very nice
attack Knight f6 looks very normal ya
hear the computer is giving a fled our
tactical win but it's not so important
from the human perspective I mean the
move Queen c1 is the computer suggestion
threatening Bishop g6 this is from a
technical point of view even a little
bit better than Wesley so smooth but the
move that you played is perfectly fine
and will ultimately win the game as well
this is very strong though black has a
really hard time to defend against the
bishops g6 idea if he goes Queenie 7 for
example clearing the queen of the D file
there's 95 hitting and this is very
awkward after takes takes the night is a
tech
it has no decent square and after the
retreat after let's say takes takes Ruby
one yeah black has a hard time now
there's Queen h6 or any kind of tactics
Queen f7 this rook h7 and black can
resign with the clear conscience what
what's the check is simply irresistible
Quincy one was also very strong but
after Knight f6 Wesley so played c5 it's
also very good move the idea is that you
clear this square also for a bishop the
idea or the point we will see here like
had to take with the f pawn after and
each pawn recaptures queen age six is
not going to end well so f cakes and now
after this Queen III and queen move
Bishop c4 we see the point of c-5 it
opened up this crucial diagonal yeah
after the capture b5 was play very nice
move not allowing any kind of counter
play closing the position there and wide
we'll win this now with this pressure
here and on the edge farm rupee one
attacking the rook and now we see this
is whoops bleep that was wrong ecigs is
the center of attention White's pressure
is far too far too big they're like we
lose this size of material yeah Gary did
some some desperado moves here chatter
after what had taken everything Kiwi
resigned yeah he would just lose stuffy
only six I'm very nice game arrest
they're so powerful game I think that
this opening idea of going if we go back
this king of one is a new move that was
very interesting and it seems that with
30 minutes spent that there was some
some effort chicken you're really over
the ball it wasn't a prepared surprise
but actually something that he thought
of over the board on
we memorized or remembered from a point
when when he studied it at some point
but maybe it was just over the bot
innovation very nice idea putting black
under pressure with those two slightly
uncoordinated pieces also the unrelated
move g6 now is really hurting black if
d5 those kind of this kind of idea that
the computer is is giving if this is
really the only completely um
satisfactory reply that black has an
King f1 is a genius idea simply because
this is so inhuman nobody is going to
play that I really don't don't see that
happening so very nice game very
powerful display black had problems out
of the opening I'm not completely sure
away it went totally downhill but right
here it is already unpleasant and I
think it was a case where those those
problems can have piled up and at some
point Gibby couldn't couldn't defend
okay let's look at the fifth game and
this is the dual of the now I have to be
careful because power off his world
champion 13 Kramnik is 14 and 15 between
the 15th and the 16th world champion um
vishy anand with white against Magnus
Carlsen the reigning world champion
let's see be she is going with e for
slightly surprising as he had played
default late mostly almost exclusively
but of course he's been a default player
in his life and the first slide
surprises coming here as cards and goes
for a six it's not going for the Berlin
Wall okay so what do we get huh is he
going for Marshall yes he is we got a
pure Marshall attack surprising not an
opening that Carlton is known to known
to play a lot if at all I mean maybe he
certainly has played it sometimes but
it's not an opening a main feature of
his repertoire
he usually plays when we when we get
that he usually plays the brea system
there he has played it against honored a
couple of times for example but here we
got the pure marshall and it's actually
quite not a surprise but well aren't
allowing it is not something that you
see every day he has played his share of
n time Marshalls as well okay so we get
this pawn sacrifice that quite often
gives black very very active peace
playing compensation for the pawn that
often is enough to get the pawn back or
really get a strong attack they're
really this is one of the rare lines and
shares wear black right of the bed can
get very strong attacking game so let's
see you three is played nowadays
probably the main move the wood main
movie is d4 and something like that yeah
where black is attacking I'm drawing
terrible arrows yeah actually think that
my mouse have some problem with this
with a mouse button yeah this kind of
attack on the light squares that will
trouble white quite often this is the
source of problems that white has in the
martial his bishop is on b3 kind of off
site on the queenside and queen edge for
forces this weakening of the light
squares where black is very often
getting a very huge initiative unplayed
d3o ever bishop d6 rookie one and here
is an interesting point black here can
play Queen edge for that's the old move
Queen age for g3 yeah note that white is
not able to play a slowish stuff like
Age 3 he's getting completely
annihilated then you absolutely cannot
afford new CEO or some kind of
second-rate move this is already am
approaching checkmate territory lexa
tech is strong so then g3 Queen here and
rookie for this is the idea of this d3
move it
leads to this possible rook swing
greenish forever is out of fashion and
this is the move that they play nowadays
Queen f3 attacking this Bishop yeah and
now look at this position what would you
play here yeah if you are not an expert
on this opening it's an interesting
moment to just pause Black is nicely
developed what kind of moves do come
into consideration your bishop is
hanging black actually has tried a
couple of moves one move for example is
rupee eight using the back rank yeah f5
Bishop is not really hanging due to the
maid threat only one that says been
played also still Queen h4s and played
there's also Queen f6 that has been
played yeah and funny and it really a
ton of moose and Queenie f6 is the
latest let's say fashion or what they
mostly play but this has been played
like 100 times and Carlton has a novelty
Bishop g6 aha a new move at this
relatively early stage move 14 you would
say early well for the marshal that's
early yeah in the in this opening you
sometimes get novelties on move 30 so
move 14 we got the got the new move in
Bishop g6 not illogical at all we just
put the bishop on g6 and say okay I'm so
nicely developed I don't care what you
do what are you doing exactly yeah and
now on and was was kind of puzzled he
didn't have this on his radar at all and
took a long time and then opted for a
very safe continuation and to be honest
when I saw that I was thinking okay this
is going to be a quick draw it wasn't we
see Alan took their own d5 it took a
long time to do that this is a very
principled decision as it transforms the
game yeah quite dramatically wyd of
course had other moves he could play 92
let's say and well then rook e8 maybe I
don't know it's it's tough to analyze
and I really cannot do that now this
would be reinventing the Marshall theory
here let's say it's a it's far more
complicated then what keeps stuff on the
ball
Alan took and plate Bishop f4 of course
it cannot take yeah we should mention
that check blundering the Queen he went
with the capture and now played Bishop
f4 that was the idea he wants to treat
rate it on d5 and now Bishop f4 further
training down if now black is yeah not
very circumspect and just takes his
landing into a very unpleasant position
Queen takes Bishop takes yeah he has
regained the pawn but have a look at
this structure the d5 pawn is isolated
and wide why have be three or f3 we get
the night on the dream square deform and
blacks bishop the light squared Bishop
is not a very good piece in this kind of
structure it kind of looks into thin air
you can put it on g6 it's not taking
anything and it's much much less
powerful than the knight on d4 so that's
not a good idea getting the porn back
like that this is pretty clear I am
black never would go for that the real
deal is something else black went deform
pretty quickly playback on black is
simply ditching this deep on and in this
way I'm getting a favorable
transformation of the pawn structure how
is this working yeah white white not
took on the form that is some quite
clear and Bishop before that's the idea
be sure before now as possible as the
sea porn has left the c3 spot we
attacked the rook yeah and white yeah
goodnight c3 and what what what could be
more natural went with this developing
news & Carlson captured on d4 so he got
one of the pawns back and we see that
with his bishop pair aggressively
pointed to c3 and d3 he should be able
to get his pawn back on are now played
Bishop b5 and here we come to a very
critical position of this game have a
look at the clock time yeah Carlson has
spent 11 minutes up to here which
basically means some he's his in
preparation
maybe he drank some orange juice took
and took a small walk or whatever but it
seems that he should still should know
about this position especially
considering that if you see that he
played this sorry that was a bit much he
played this novelty and move 14 the
white continuation here is kind of the
first thing that you check because it's
very principled taking their Bishop f4
now he absolutely must have had this
position in his in his preparation and
now he played the move Queen to d7 first
thing we should check is why is he not
taking the pawn yeah note he took a
couple of minutes there right it's not
it's not like he just plays what he
knows I'm Queen d3 that is the most
obvious move first I was thinking okay
well there has to be some some kind of
glitch there some kind of hidden
drawback maybe glitches the wrong word
but it has to be some kind of problem
with the move but it doesn't seem to be
the case the only thing is that when you
look at it and you don't know it it
looks a bit awkward in some lines let's
say I one place rookie 3 Quincy 495 this
position looks really awkward because
black is a bit uncoordinated at the
moment yeah the night is attacking this
bishop so the queen is in a bit of an
unstable spotted it's always has to keep
the bishop protected also you think
sometimes of those checks that mum are
possible or Knight f6 check so this
position looks a bit shaky but it seems
that if you want to believe the engine
and I tend to believe the engine in a
very open position like that there is
nothing going on it just says 0 yeah or
0.1 or something it seems that there is
no direct problem for black and if there
is no direct problem some kind of tactic
black is totally fine however this is
not easy to determine over the board it
is strange however that cars had to
determine it over the board if you play
a novelty 14 Bishop g6 it seems that you
should should know that
it looks very very like a very very very
logical cause of events however he went
queen to d7 and preparation preparation
or not the issue is after Queen d7 um
well I'm not quite sure what what Carson
calculated but he probably did not
really appreciate 95 correctly which was
now played by add a very very nice move
he just ignores the pin and puts the
knight on d5 the big problem is if black
takes that Jack is getting completely
destroyed Knight f6 very nice ER after
takes Queen takes there's made on g7 and
it's absolutely impossible to prevent
very very nice motif it seems that Carla
simply overlooked that motive when you
have played Queen d7 once you see 95
that it is in the position um yeah you
see the point there i am but it seems
that he has to um yeah it must be that
yes miscalculated some some line there I
did not see the postgame interviews or
press conference or whatever maybe he
explained what what was happening there
but the big issue is now black is in
huge trouble Knight f6 is a threat
anyway yeah note that the queen is in
this form so black cannot just move the
king it's a terrible threat also the
night is of course attacking the bishop
and threatening Knight b6 yeah when I
first saw it I was in a while this is
the resins on what no black can actually
continue the game and this is kind of
lucky if it was really a complete
oversight that you did not see 95 at all
here and f6 now which is yeah kind of
preventing the 90 of six move and he is
counter attacking this so after night
takes fe5 black is regaining the piece
but it's still in trouble after chandi
five chick takes takes Bishop takes the
three rookie five after this sequence
Black is just a clear porn down yeah in
the Marshall you're used to that
but normally you have some kind of
compensation and this is not the case
here this is just a clean clean pawn and
nothing more nothing less when I saw
this in the live broadcast I was some I
would have bet quite some amount on them
on a wide win um I think what you mean
you really think why should win this
somehow you know it why doesn't have any
weakness in his pawn structure he has a
nice night on d5 that also has a stable
square only three and hmm there's no
particular reason why black should draw
that I mean besides the the general yeah
drawing tendencies that you get in case
of more pawns traded and so on but enjoy
you would think white should be able to
win this but now we see the next couple
of moves we see some points and it gives
you a clear indication how tough a
defender our current world champion is
you played rook e8 after some long
thought 27 minutes and this is a an
excellent i mean the the the way how we
assess the one upcoming position i find
really remarkable if you look at this
what did honor now do he took some time
check hey traded and put the night to
III in this position however white had
an alternative what about the move night
before it looks great right it takes
upon that takes the bishop how is black
defending this and that's a very
interesting play at first you think it's
a clean double attack and why just win
the pawn but things are not at all clear
black plays Bishop c4 ok ok what about
96 then aha black can take on a to the
week back rank all of a sudden we see
why it hasn't won materia it is just the
trade yeah and we now have the pawn
count reduced on the queenside with only
be pawns there you have to understand
that if we get to a position where
everything is just on the Kings side
against to the likelihood of a draw is
is really really high so this is
something that black definitely is not
afraid of but what about be three what
about this first attacking the bishop
then taking an opponent okay the thing
is even here black has interesting
counterplay ideas he goes a five very
interesting if white now takes the
bishop takes their takes their rookie
five we see that black gets the pawn and
he has now gotten to a rook ending which
is a huge achievement in comparison as
rook endings and notoriously draws in
this particular case is actually
directly a draw because after any kind
of there are many sequences to get there
but you get to a situation where those
two pawns will trade each other and then
we have three against two so it's just a
complete draw however what about Knight
to c6 very interesting line why does it
taking a five and the bishop is attacked
okay Bishop to d5 why it takes the pawn
and now let's say remove like rook c8
possibly intending Roxy to why these two
pawns up and this line is forced it's
totally forced so you would take two
pawns there must be winning okay if you
say that that you think it's a win
you're welcome to show me the winner I
couldn't find any win it looks really
weird it's two pawns but blacks bishop
there on d5 it's very well placed and
the night at the moment is dominated the
pawn right to the side of the board led
to position where it's absolutely not
clear how wide should proceed in fact if
you play something very careless like a
for your even losing the game all of the
summer and the night is lost okay that's
very very heavy brutal brutal way to
lose for white but what exactly are you
doing how are you going to make any
progress
you play B form to support the night
okay there are this more than one idea
you can you can take again because of
the back rank but also black if we just
assume that this would happen in a
different position I just want to show
how big blacks strategic compensation is
if he just puts the rock down and just
then just sit or maybe maybe let's say
he approaches with the King drawing
nonsense yeah maybe I have to get a new
mouse if he attack if he approaches with
the king how is white going to make any
progress let's just say f3 can hear a
form yeah I'll take it and then okay
from this position how are you going to
get anywhere the night is still
dominated if you move the beep on well
at the moment it's black smooth let's
say I'm getting you some checks check
and maybe go here so what is Phi doing
now you cannot move the night from a 5
anywhere the B porn is under the tech
and it's in protected by this rook so
you cannot move the rook very likely why
it has to give up the beep on you're not
getting anywhere without rook and night
and if this is happening again what are
you doing with your night there it is
dominated yeah and this is this kind of
thing we already know as being um yeah
basically a draw from the get-go so I
think this some if we go back there with
rupee 8,000 had to have seen this yeah
that that he can give up the porn on a
64 domination that's that's fantastic in
my book so a very very nice piece of
calculation there Knight b6 it's not on
assessment let's say what cannot really
play night before with any any hopeful
success for for success if white is
going for 97 by the way like is directly
entering with the with the Lucani to and
again yes excellent counter play
yeah and I just went 93 you played that
quickly probably having decided on that
when he took on yet rook c8 yeah note
that the night is also covering the sea
to square when I saw his end game I
thought well okay come on this should be
a win for wide but we see in the next
couple of moves and I think we're
dealing with fairly logical moves from
both sides we see in this in this
process that black put this pawn on b3
and the idea is that you're basically
upping the stakes a little bit on the
queenside whenever you get the B pawn in
some kind of um trade your be three Pawn
would be dangerous so you're pushing
your candidate forward let's say with
the pawn coming to be three now why it
has this problem you cannot so easily
move this night yeah if you I mean what
did i do we played kingi too but let's
just say at one point you want to want
to move your night I mean at this
particular moment is possible because of
the this mating idea there on the eight
but whenever you move the night aware
you have to be alert that rooks it to
its not coming all of a sudden attacking
the beep on ya uh not first strengthen
his position yeah those little moves do
help improve I have to admit though that
now we're coming to the part of the game
we're a little bit stuck because I'm
absolutely unsure how to improve on our
ins play I'm going to spoil it right
away it ended in a draw cards are
actually managed to hold this position
we can do it like that let's look at how
it was played and then we can try form a
possible improvement and white was going
for an invasion there with night and
rook it looks completely not to check
yeah on the seventh I mean black looks
completely completely in the ropes but
somehow it's it's still kind of hurts
King back to g8 covering f7
he had some repetition down and then
I'll i was going for 96 bishop went here
i can tell you the moment when when uh
none spoiled it to a draw on it safe but
i have no clear improvement that wins
this is a the catch here in this moment
he played the move King to f5 and
looking at this with the computer head
will tell you okay this is the move that
spoiled that definitely ends the end of
any promising winning ambitions but i
have no clear-cut way to improve let's
just say what happened Luke c6 was the
reply when the night Hanks and the porn
hangs like that sorry for the wrong
arrows I guess I have to replace this
mouse yeah and now White has a problem
he has to do something about the night
and as mentioned whenever you remove the
night from you three let's say you go
back all of a son there is counter plane
you know and it seems that this is
enough for black black to draw the game
also capture their and on b2 rook
endgame will also be very very dry yeah
I'm on plate kingi five and after Bishop
f3 knight f5 they're all of a sudden g5
is coming and black is covering age six
if you still looks kind of terrible but
okay you're covering age six g4 is
hanging yeah and how do you win witness
white now there is nothing yeah the
computer is just giving a very very yeah
for from white rights kind of view
disappointing 0054 something here like
nothing yeah island check played this
check if you take like just recaptures
and we see that g4 is going to fall Jeff
that's really amazing he went for checks
and now rook g6
but after King age seven there is no win
yeah amazingly after the rook trade
black always has this counter Flames
Bishop f3 the g4 porn it's a is a
vulnerable part of whites camp and is
absolutely no window check yeah he gave
cheques and I think here they agree to a
draw something that must have been very
disappointing for violent who was some
yeah better after Carlton's opening
opening mistake there I cannot really
tell you let's just go a little bit back
down yeah I really I would be very
surprised if white had made any mistake
up to the let's say this point but I
have no clear idea how to win must I
must say I mean okay things I'm
analyzing this I'm the much weaker
player compared to two honored the
computer is not giving you any kind of
hint it just shuffles around and I just
looked for five to ten minutes and I
couldn't find anything with just no big
shame well Allen didn't even find a win
as well I absolutely cannot improve on
on what what he did it's clear that with
this one particular moment should we go
down and here this is some problem due
to very concrete technical reason
basically a double attack if you want of
course hear hear you can you can exactly
at this position you can try to play
better but the point the problem is how
exactly are you going to improve your
position how are you going to make any
headway if you go to f5 black goes back
we have seen that before and well what
exactly is your winning plan black
always has this counter play as I said
this is the point of pushing the porn
all the way to be three if you get me to
this is very serious I don't see when I
mean no shame but i really i really have
no idea if and when if an how white
actually
would have could have won this end game
would be interesting to look at any any
in a very deep way but I couldn't get
anywhere I mean the night looks very
good on f5 it's difficult to improve on
that the computer in some lines actually
if we go back a moment the computer
sometimes suggested ideas with putting
the night there the idea to play it to
g6 maybe this is an idea but if you go
look back what exactly is the point of
it not sure maybe King g3 fy5 maybe this
night edge for ideas some is worth worth
considering if you go rook c2 and trying
to attack this Bishop g6 was the idea
but even here let's say black plays
Bishop you aid rook pin king of seven
how is white going to win this the B
porn is falling it's tricky it's
absolutely not easy at all maybe you
find some windows some analysts who is
able to invest more time but I couldn't
certainly as mentioned kind of a
disappointing finish of this game for
honored and very close call for the
world champion okay this was the first
round of this tournament it again as
usual got a lot longer than I wanted but
I hope you enjoyed this round one
coverage I'm back tomorrow with round
two thanks for watching